the tale of sir gawain and the green
knight
although it is somewhat outside of the
canon of arthurian legend is nonetheless
one of the most known stories
within these arthurian stories and so
i want to look at the story of sir
gawain look at the
symbolism that's there i will probably
make this video in two parts
the first part will be kind of
explaining
the uh setup of the story tell you the
story
uh the first part of the story and then
look at the symbolism that's involved in
there
and in the next patron only video we'll
do the second part as well
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
so i'll give you a basic sense of the
story of the first part of the story
of course this is going to be very
summery if you're interested in
this uh story it's it's very much worth
reading it's very well written
it's a it's one of the finer of the
medieval romances
and uh i don't know if you can call it
romance but at least medieval
legends or stories and so the story
starts in
the court of king arthur and so king
arthur has these
massive parties with all the knights of
the round table
and the story is happening during
yuletide during the time of christmas
more specifically at the new year it is
a new year's feast
and it is customary for
arthur to not eat until he has
heard of some story some challenge
some adventure that his knights or the
people in his court had
had gone into and so while this is
happening while everybody is kind of
waiting
to see what's going to happen a
giant green knight walks in to the
castle
the story takes a lot of time to
describe his armor
his clothing his hair that is green and
gold and his horse is green he is green
his clothe is green everything about him
is green with gold ornamentation
so this green knight walks in and says
that he wants to
offer a challenge to the court of king
arthur
and his challenge is that he asked that
one person in the court comes
and takes one blow at his neck with his
axe and whoever is willing to do that
will get a full blow at his neck on the
promise
that in the year that comes
that person will then accept to be dealt
the same blow
and so everybody's kind of silent
everybody's kind of wondering what is
going on this
this massive giant green knight walking
in
and offering such a strange challenge
and so king arthur
is kind of waiting and finally because
no one is speaking up
king arthur speaks up and you know says
that he is going to do it
and as he is getting ready to do it
gwenevere encourages
sir gawain to propose himself
as the one to take the challenge
so sir gawain accepts the challenge
walks up to the green knight
and the green knight places himself
exposes his neck
gawain takes a swing cuts the head
off the green knight but then the green
knight reaches down
grabs his own head in his hand gets back
on his horse
and says in one year exactly one year
from now
you are to meet me at the green chapel
in order to receive your blow and the
green knight
leaves and so
then sir gawain waits the whole year
very uneasily everybody is kind of
uneasy about the situation knows what is
coming
wondering what's going to happen and the
whole story kind of passes through the
seasons
and then moves all the way to
uh all hallows day which is
the you know it's after halloween the
day after halloween
all hallows day the day where all the
dead
are all the saints are celebrated and
all the dead are
celebrated in that period and that is
when
the uh that is when uh gawain
decides to go off on his journey and
starts to move out in order to find the
green chapel
and he goes out and moves into the
forest
and gets kind of lost in the forest and
he moves with north wales you know which
is understood at this
this kind of far away place you know
where all the celts were
were pushed later on in in a uh
in um in medieval history and so he kind
of wanders through the forest his loss
and everything
and then finally he on christmas
eve he perceives the light of a castle
in the distance and goes and finds
refuge in the castle
and in the castle is where the rest of
the adventure is going to take part but
i want to focus
just on the first part of galway's story
right now
and look at some of the symbolism that
we already see in
this story so it's really
important to understand the story of
sierra gawain to
understand the the cycle of the year and
the symbolism
of the year itself and so
gawain the green knight appears at
the arthur's castle at new year's and so
in the description
there's a description of yule tide of
the time of around
you know during the christmas season but
also the new year
and so we need to understand the moment
where this happens
as the end and the beginning of
something
and so it's related of course to the
solstice
in terms of the day the lowest day of
the sun it's related to this transition
between the old and the new
the transition towards the new year and
so this is what we are seeing
happening in this moment
and so the green night it's very
it's difficult to be precise at what the
green night means but there is
definitely
a relationship between the green knight
and the idea of
this primordial forest the idea of the
ancient world and so if you know a
little bit about medieval culture
you know a little bit about the green
men and the
the notion of these green ornamental
figures that were carved in churches
and represent this kind of man-made of
foliage
and a you know a kind of ancient
primordial world
a world before before the romanization
before christianity
and i think that that's really what the
green man
manifests we will learn later that he is
actually doing this under the guise of
morgan le fay this
witch uh this kind of sorceress who is
ambiguous and strange and also seems to
represent a residue of the ancient world
there's also a relationship between the
green man and
merlin from some of the stories where
merlin is represented as this wild
man as a you know as this wild man who
lives in the forest and so
the none of these associations are
direct they're somewhat
indirect uh there's also relationships
to other other cultures other traditions
which
also use the notion of the green man i
think
it is related to this
a figure in islamic storytelling who is
known as al-khadir
and who is a a figure that appears in
the quran as
posing enigmas to moses moses meets this
strange mysterious figure who's not
actually named in the quran but who
is named later in tradition and
the uh the the figure poses enigmas that
that uh that moses is not able to
answer these very strange enigmas and
it's really
if you watch my video on the the story
of silence you will see
there's a connection in that story
between merlin
and uh al khadir and then also here in
the notion of the green man which is
the posing of a mystery the posing of
something which is
before logic and doesn't make sense and
represents
a world which is before the reasonable
ordered world and so
you can imagine it as this kind of burst
of the ancient world into
the the court of king arthur and this
burst of the ancient world represents
itself as this kind of primordial
wild verdant green the forest it
represents itself also as a challenge
to order a challenge to order which
doesn't seem to make sense because
the challenge is is a challenge which is
illogical
the the figure is saying cut my head off
right that's the challenge is it
and so there's a strange contradiction
in the challenge something which like i
said
precedes order doesn't fit within the
normal
battle challenge that would usually
appear right the knight
didn't come and say fight me he said
come and
and basically cut my head off which
doesn't make sense
but it makes sense if you understand it
in the time of the transition between
the old and the new
if you understand the cutting of the
head of the green man
as the solstice itself as the cutting
off of the
old year as the cutting off of the sun
which is going down
into the earth you can understand what
is happening at this moment
and so the challenge is for gawain
to chop the head off the old world to
basically inaugurate the new year
and so there is a mystery in
doing that because in cutting off
the head of the old of the old
and inaugurating the new you throw
yourself into a cycle
you can understand it in there are
several stories that talk about this
for example the story of the castrating
of the
of the god of heaven in greek mythology
where
you castrate the father god the old god
the old legion of god that
that aren't you you castrate that
sometimes it's a dismembering of an
ancient figure a dismembering of an
ancient giant
uh there are there are different
versions of the same story where
you break apart you dismember you cut
off the head of that which was before
and that is what launches the new year
because you you basically cut the head
off and you have this new body that you
can reorganize
into a new world uh and so like i said
but once
when you do that you inaugurate the
cycle of revolution
and so if you chop if you castrate the
father
the father god then you are also going
to be castrated
afterwards maybe not castrated you are
going to be eaten by your father right
so so uh saturn cuts
the the genitals off of his father but
then
he ends up like eating his children but
then that kind of flips and so there's
this weird
like flip that keeps happening and then
finally zeus
ends up killing his father or you know
dismembering his father or hurting his
father or whatever i forget
actually how it goes but it doesn't
matter the idea is this
relationship between the old guard and
the new guard
this is what we're seeing happening and
so
gawain cuts the head off the off
the this ancient world but then the
the challenge is that if he does that in
a year at the solstice once again
is when he is going to get his head cut
off as well right
he has kind of thrown himself into that
loop and
and so that is what is happening and you
make sense in the story itself because
as you see
it happens the beginning of his quest
happens at
hal all hallows all hallows is midway
between the equinox and the solstice
and so it is in that moment because at
the equinox you have this
balance between the two day the day and
the night right you have this
equilibrium but it's an
it's a it's an equilibrium which is
going down
and so halfway between the equinox and
the solstice is where you really would
start to notice
and you would really start to experience
the diminishing of the days and the
diminishing of the year
and so gawain as the one who cut the
head off the
previous year is now going into
the darkness and entering into the the
dark world moving out into the margin
where he is now going to experience
getting his head cut off
and so as he approaches in the forest of
course he gets lost
and he perceives the castle in
the in the distance and what's going to
happen in the castle
is really going to be his going out into
the margin and experiencing
everything about being in the world of
the margin
including a weird upside down reality in
which he's going
to get into and and it's going to also
be a test of his identity
a test which he is going to not
completely
uh he's not completely going to
be uh the conqueror in this test he is
going to give in
a little bit and this giving in is
ultimately though going to
end up turning back into his favor and
so we're going to look
at the second part of the story of sir
gawain
and the green knight uh in my next
patron only video
as you may have noticed this video was
first put out as a patron only video in
september 2020
i'm also going to be putting out the
second part of my analysis of sir gawain
in a week from now
and so i'm really driving people these
days to go to my website and to sign up
at the bottom of the website to
subscribe to the website
as uh internet censorship is going up
as we feel the pressure from social
media to say certain things and to not
say other things
i'm hoping to remain as free as possible
if you subscribe to the website then you
have
a better chance of having news from what
i'm doing even if youtube bans me or if
i get shadow band whatever can happen if
you're subscribed to the website you
will
be able to follow what we're doing not
only the videos but also
the blog where we have several people
writing about symbolism
some pretty amazing writers there as
well and you'll be able to follow all
the new changes that are going on
i will be integrating the clips channel
into the website i'll also be
having a french part to the website as
well you can follow all that news
if you subscribe and so thanks for your
support everybody and i'll talk to you
very soon